29 de octubre y es momento de hablar de
economía y por ello recibo y con
muchísimo gusto a d'angelo hablando con
ramírez nuestra especialista muy buenas
noches daniela bienvenida empezamos con
la economía de eeuu pues parece que se
recuperó en el tercer trimestre alan muy
buenas noches de la economía de eeuu
creció a un ritmo récord entre julio y
septiembre de términos trimestrales esto
quiere decir que lo comparamos frente a
los tres meses anteriores lo que impulsó
el resultado fue el gasto de los
consumidores y la inversión empresarial
que se dispararon en este periodo el
crecimiento del tercer trimestre de 330
y 3,1 por ciento contrasta con las
contracciones que se habían visto en los
trimestres anteriores como vemos en el
gráfico más del 30 por ciento en el
segundo trimestre y un 5% en el primero
los analistas atribuyen este resultado
en parte al gran paquete de alivios de
más de 3 billones de dólares expedido en
marzo y que sirvió para la reapertura
económica en los siguientes veces pero
todavía hay millones de desempleados en
la última semana 1 751 mil
y dieron subsidios y varias empresas
estadounidenses no les está yendo tan
mal durante la pandemia cuáles son las
que les está yendo mejor y cuáles están
siendo duramente impactadas bueno por
esos días están conociendo los
resultados trimestrales de todas las
empresas que cotizan en bolsa con corte
al tercer trimestre y hay pocas
sorpresas relativamente las grandes
tecnológicas están disfrutando de
ingresos y ganancias excepcionales
gracias al auge que han tenido en estos
tiempos por ejemplo amazon alphabet que
es la matriz de google y facebook
elevaron entre enero y septiembre sus
ingresos entre el 8 y el 35 por ciento
por su parte de apple facturó casi
280.000 millones de dólares en los
últimos 12 meses pero en otros sectores
como el petrolero la situación es
totalmente contraria porque hay una
menor demanda del crudo los grandes
jugadores de la industria como por
ejemplo british petroleum cel o repsol
reportaron millonarias pérdidas en los
primeros nueve meses esto ha hecho que
muchas de ellas anuncien en recortes de
personal como exxonmobil
estoy dijo que va a despedir a otros mil
900 empleados
seguimos hablando de los que han sabido
sortear la pandemia y sus impactos
negativos económicos momento de china
china es la única de las grandes
economías que se va del lujo de crecer
este año y ya está pensando en los
siguientes el comité central del partido
comunista chino presentó este jueves su
plan quinquenal económico que apunta
entre otras cosas a elevar el pib per
cápita usada por personas a los niveles
que tienen los países desarrollados la
innovación y la autosuficiencia
tecnológica son dos de los pilares de
este plan a 2025 dentro del cual las
grandes empresas tecnológicas van a
jugar un gran papel también se busca
fomentar el consumo interno y potenciar
las industrias emergentes estas
decisiones fueron tomadas a puerta
cerrada tras una reunión de cuatro días
de los 365 dirigentes del partido y
serán llevadas al legislativo debido al
menor flujo de emigrantes daniela pues
las remesas van a querer incluso dos
años
no soy lo que espera el banco mundial
que prevee que se reduzcan en un 14%
entre 2020 y 2021 frente a los niveles
récord que había antes de la pandemia en
los países de ingresos bajos y medios
las remesas podrían bajar un 7% este año
hasta un poco más de 500 mil millones de
dólares y el próximo año bajaría en una
proporción similar la razón sencilla la
crisis económica que genera menos
empleos en los países que acogen a los
migrantes y que a su vez envían dinero a
familiares desde sus países a sus países
de origen pero también la devaluación de
las monedas las regiones más afectadas
según el organismo serán europa y asia
oriental bonos con los indicadores
económicos como esta en el día de hoy
wall street se recuperó de una difícil
jornada del miércoles gracias a los
datos de crecimiento económico y sus
índices cerraron en positivo en europa
las malas perspectivas del banco central
europeo hicieron que todas las bolsas
excepto fráncfort bajarán y en américa
latina' cierres mixtos en la bolsa de
buenos aires rompió una racha negativa
de tres jornadas
cerramos daniela con cifra del día son
los 15 mil millones de euros que le
costará al estado cada mes el
confinamiento que inicia este viernes en
francia los recursos son utilizados en
fondos de solidaridad subsidios de
desempleo exoneraciones de cotizaciones
sociales y parte de los costos de
alquiler de las empresas hablan muy bien
daniela pues muchas gracias por este
recorrido económico y ustedes muchas
gracias por su compañía ya lo sabe para
más información y el momento aquí en
francés 24
i
[Música]